all day long i drift around this big
building
and then all of a sudden at 5 30 the
building comes to life
there's this mad flurry of activity
people start filing in and the
excitement builds and this is what we're
here for
my name is ann nelson i am the owner
operator steward of the patricia theater
with my son brian and the resident
theater cat princess diva
we live in an isolated area so the
number of people that depend on the
theater for their entertainment is the
whole regional district that's 21 000
people and you can only reach us by air
or by water
i try really hard to have a huge variety
of programming because there's not the
option to say oh well i'll just go to
the next town
the closest movie theater to powell
river is a minimum two hours in a car on
a ferry and over a hundred dollars in
travel costs plus a motel because you're
not coming home the same night
since 1913
it has been the patricia entertainment
company and it has always been the
social hub for entertainment in this
community
fourteen years ago there was a very real
risk that the community could have lost
its only movie theater
the only people who were interested in
it were developers who were going to
tear it down and use the view property
and so it was really important to the
community that it it kept functioning
and so we did it we saved the theater
i live in the building
so while this beautiful theater is
sleeping i get to have my own life
upstairs and pretend that i'm invisible
for a little while
originally i had thought i can do this
till i'm 70. it's cool
now i'm 74 this year i can do this till
i'm 80. you know it's cool
there's nothing like walking into a
darkened auditorium and either be with
friends or instantly make friends with
whom you're laughing or crying or
gasping
there's nothing like that in in your
living room
this place is special it deserves to
survive
you